foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter theory in today's video we're
going to be discussing none other than
popular Hufflepuff student Cedric
Diggory more specifically however we're
going to be discussing his untimely
death at the hands of wormtail make a
Peter Pettigrew during the penultimate
moments of the Goblet of Fire now
whether you're a film goer or a book
reader the untimely death of Cedric
Diggory was no doubt impactful it
happened during the third challenge of
the Triwizard Tournament just after
Harry and Cedric simultaneously clutched
the tri-wizard cup unbeknown to them
however the Triwizard cup was actually a
portkey a port key that sent them
straight to wormtail Voldemort and
little hangleton graveyard it was here
that Cedric lived out his final moments
ultimately reaching his fate at the
hands of Peter Pettigrew and his killing
curse this is outlined in chapter 32 of
the Goblet of Fire Flesh Blood and Bone
Harry felt his feet slammed into the
ground his injured leg gave way and he
fell forward his hand let go of the
tri-wizard cup at last he raised his
head where are we he said Cedric shook
his head he got up pulled Harry to his
feet and they looked around they had
left the Hogwarts grounds completely
they had obviously traveled miles
perhaps hundreds of miles for even the
mountains surrounding the castle were
gone they were standing inside a dark
and overgrown graveyard the black
outline of a small church was visible
Beyond a large yew tree to their right
they pulled out their ones Harry kept
looking around him he had yet again the
strange feeling that they were being
watched someone's coming he said
suddenly squinting tensely through the
darkness they watched the figure drawing
nearer walking steadily toward them
between the graves Harry lowered his one
slightly and glanced sideways at Cedric
Cedric shot him a quizzical look they
both turned back to watch the
approaching figure it stopped beside a
towering marble headstone only six feet
from them for second Harry and Cedric
and the short figure simply looked at
one another and then without warning
Harry's scar exploded with pain it was
Agony such as he had never felt in all
his life his wand slipped from his
fingers as he put his hands over his
face his knees buckled he was on the
ground and he could see nothing at all
his head was about to split open from
far away above his head he had a high
cold voice say kill the spare a swishing
noise and a second voice which Screech
the words to the night Avada Kedavra a
blast of green light blazed through
Harry's eyelids and he heard something
heavy fall to the ground beside him the
pain in his scar reached such a pitch
that he wretched and then it diminished
terrified of what he was about to see he
opened his stinging eyes Cedric was
lying spread eagle on the ground beside
him he was dead for a second that
contained an eternity Harry stared into
Cedric's face at his open gray eyes
blank an expressionless as the windows
of a deserted house and his half open
mouth which looked slightly surprised
and that was the last time we ever saw
Cedric alive the popular Hufflepuff
student and promising young wizard
before we go any further I want to make
one thing clear this what if is not
fueled by the circumstances of the
cursed child if you didn't know already
the Cedric Diggory from the cursed child
turns evil however the rationale behind
Cedric changing allegiances in that
timeline is primarily driven by the fact
that he was embarrassed by his extremely
unfortunate circumstances and that they
somehow tarnished his reputation however
to me this doesn't mesh well with
Cedric's character sure Cedric had a
certain amount of pride and honor
pertaining to his magical ability and
Status at Hogwarts I get it but the
notion that he would somehow become a
Pure Evil just because he inaccurately
determined that his status was now lost
makes no sense how could only
embarrassment push an otherwise
level-headed man to Madness furthermore
it's ridiculous to assume that this same
embarrassment would push Cedric to seek
Vengeance for his non-existent
humiliation to add to this the rationale
behind Cedric surviving in the cursed
child comes down to Harry's son Albus
and draco's Son Scorpius messing with a
Time Turner with the time Turner they
traveled decades back in time and save
his life given the delicate nature of
the fabric of time not a fan of this
answer however with that said I still
want to explore a what if pertaining to
Cedric surviving I'm just going to
approach it in a very different way
first let's start with a brief recap on
who Cedric is Cedric Diggory was a
British pure blood wizard born in the
year 1977 he began studying at Hogwarts
in the year 1989 two years before Harry
Potter and the trio Cedric was a
talented Wizard and was sorted into
Hufflepuff house in his formative year
at Hogwarts Cedric had a reputation of
being a bit of a pretty boy but was well
liked by the student body eventually
becoming prefect for Hufflepuff house
and captain of the Hufflepuff Quidditch
team Cedric notably competed against
Harry in the trial was a tournament and
it was here that Cedric was tragically
killed but was he really killed first
off I'm going to discuss a what if
scenario that addresses his possible
survival we know that Peter Pettigrew
was the one to fire the Fatal killing
curse at Cedric and to any casual
Observer Cedric was quite evidently dead
Harry saw Cedric's gray blank
expressionless eyes first hand and when
he finally escaped the graveyard he
brought Cedric's motionless body back
with him this meant that many others saw
Cedric's lifeless body confirming that
his death had in fact occurred however
what if Peter pettigrew's Avada Kedavra
wasn't actually powerful enough to kill
Cedric in the Goblet of Fire we're
taught that the unforgivable curses
crucio imperio and most importantly
Avada Kedavra require a lot of powerful
magic to be successfully cast Avada
Kedavra is a curse that needs a powerful
bit of magic behind it you could all get
your ones out and point them at me and
say the words and I doubt I'd get so
much as a nosebleed so in this what if
scenario I want to explore the
possibility that Peter pettigrew's
killing curse wasn't actually powerful
enough to properly kill Cedric it only
got him most of the way at this stage
Voldemort hadn't yet returned to his
proper form and there was a lot of
pressure on Pettigrew to make sure that
everything went according to plan
because of this pressure and because
Pettigrew had been left to his own
devices for so many years he simply
lacked the power concentration necessary
to properly execute the curse this meant
that after Cedric Diggory was buried on
a beautiful Hill he actually woke up
after waking up Cedric needed answers
and the first person to realize that
Cedric had been reawakened was Voldemort
who used legilimency to invade his mind
while exploring his mind Voldemort saw a
lot of confusion with an element of
underlying anger anger that he wanted to
capitalize on infiltrating his thoughts
Voldemort eventually convented Cedric to
meet with him when they meet Voldemort
has already sussed him up and knows
exactly how to trigger his emotions Cho
Chang he uses the gilamency to show
Cedric Harry with Cho and while at first
Cedric ignored it he's eventually pushed
to his absolute limit when Voldemort
shows Harry kissing Cho he convinces
Cedric that it was Harry's plan all
along to bring him to the graveyard and
that he used him always in pursuit of
Cedric's love interest Cho this drive
Cedric to insanity but Voldemort didn't
stop there he explained to him that
everyone thought that he was dead and
that no one would accept him anymore he
also explained that no one would ever
believe his side of the story that the
boy who lived would commit such
atrocities this turned Cedric to the
dark side and becomes just another
unnamed Death Eater from here Cedric
actively participates in The Wizarding
War hiding under his Death Eater mask
out of Shame however when the fall of
Voldemort becomes apparent Cedric
Retreats and travels far away from here
Cedric vows to destroy Harry Potter in
exactly the same way that Voldemort
wanted to destroy him he isolates
himself from the rest of the Wizarding
World and begins to hone his already
advanced magical abilities effectively
becoming the next big threat after
Voldemort and that's it for this what if
I hope you enjoyed it just having a bit
of fun if you enjoy the content please
like the video and subscribe to the
channel until next time
we'll celebrate a boy who was kind and
honest and brave and true right to the
very end
[Music]